some libertarians are against the public
school system they would close down the
public school system do you think this
is a good thing or do you believe in it
well I don't think the public school
system has a real good record I think
the educational quality is very very low
and getting lower all the time I think
that you can go to some of the big
cities and you find out that it's the
schools are drug infested in crime
infested and there's violence and very
little education more than a million
kids drop out a year before they get
their high school diploma it's an armed
fortress and so we think the record is
very poor so we have concern about good
education and of course we want to go in
the direction of privatizing all schools
but in the very practical world of
politics I don't think it's wise for me
to say that tomorrow we could have
private schools I don't think it's
likely gonna happen so we can do a whole
lot set our ideals work toward it and we
could change the whole I think where we
really have gone astray
has been in this century where we have
gotten in in probably last 30 or 4 years
when we got the federal government
involved and the local governments have
been involved in schools most of our
history and I think if we had the
federal government out of it in the
state governments and schools were
controlled locally although that
wouldn't be perfect libertarianism it
would be a far cry better than what we
have but even short of doing all that we
as libertarians would really promote a
little competition we don't like
monopolies when they're government
monopolies because that's really the
only government only monopoly you get a
monopoly of our school system is is a
great danger so we would immediately
introduce the idea and we think it would
help the schools right off and that is
allow tax credits or vouchers for people
who want prayer in the schools I think
we force people in prayer in school you
know that's a violation of civil
liberties but what we could do is say if
you don't wanna Kawai your kids are
being taught let's allow you to have
competition let's give you a tax credit
or a voucher and go down the street and
have the kind of school you want so we
would want competition that to me would
be a practical alternative and
moving in the right direction